he just tries to get everyone on his
side and play the victim and it's really
not fair
Scott Disick at the center of Kardashian
family drama once again kind of agree
with Scott on this one this is Kourtney
she's going to be difficult on Sunday's
episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Kourtney was furious after
learning that thought introduced their
three kids to his 20 year-old girlfriend
Sophia Ricci without telling her first
years Scott side of the story which he
relayed to Kris Jenner over the phone
[Music]
[Music]
kourt's argument is that Scott went
against a previous combo the exes had in
therapy about doing what's best for
their kid owes the thought of my kids
being introduced to another woman and
having somebody else in their lives I
think it's hard for me and hard for them
there's a lot going on for them and I
know that it can be confusing but here's
the especially confusing part at the
time eight year-old Mason six year old
Penelope and three-year-old rein had
already met Court then boyfriend Eunice
Benjamin needless to say all the drama
led to one very tense conversation
between Scott and Kourtney I will bet
you one billion dollars it's not a human
being that you know don't go with what
exactly I just said your own family so
you're in denial I've been doing pretty
much everything since day one and if
you're not able to follow the guidelines
sit girl later in the episode it was
crisp to the rescue with a few words of
wisdom I think she is trying to cope
when Courtney gets upset she often
responds the same way I do which isn't
pretty and in the end got apologized to
court and all seemed to be well once
again after talking to Chris I realized
that she's been there and she gets it
more than anybody my biggest mistake was
not being as clear as possible should
have told Courtney exactly what was
happening I did see his side a little
bit also on Sunday Sophia opened up
about her relationship with Scott in an
interview with The Sydney Morning Herald
and explained that they are best friends
first and foremost quote we have always
had that best friend connection and from
there it has really worked out I am so
happy we are very happy very lovey-dovey
my parents always told me should just be
independent so I've always kind of run
by that just to be my own person do what
I want don't let people get in my head
[Music]
[Applause]